[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the vr drop zone a first of
its kind collaboration between br
betting
and draftkings we are live in the
bleacher report app
and this entire show was created so that
we could give you an exclusive first
look at draftkings
biggest super bowl props my name is
cabby richards this is our betting
expert in big bang kelly stewart
and the leader of the winners only army
please say the please
greg ivory and you know you guys may
know us as the regular squad ride crew
but for the br drop zone we had to bring
in a heavy hitter
we are proud to bring in one of our
favorite humans alive an
nfl legend and the honorary commissioner
of the vr betting crew
chad ocho cinco johnson welcome sir
we we show you we have so much love for
you man
thank you i appreciate it i'm glad to be
here i'm happy
i'm eating krispy kreme donuts this is
going to be a fabulous
fabulous show this really is live this
is live for real
chad before we get into the props which
game was more surprising last night the
afc championship game or the nfc
championship game
um you know what i expected great games
out of all the teams that played
but if there was a surprise it would
probably be
i expected the packers to win i expected
the packers to win no
not not i don't mean to go against brady
but what aaron rodgers was able to do
with devonta out of the season
was unskewed you know what believable it
was crazy so i
expected him to breathe not breathe
through the game or at least win and
they missed some easy opportunities
to win that game especially with the
turnovers that tom had
[Music]
oh real talk i was in my bag a little
bit last night but
uh all right let's let's get things
moving here just to kick things off chad
we're just gonna show you how
how we do things around here with the
help of the fans
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the fomo is real and shirts are always
optional when celebrating
uh now it doesn't matter if you're
riding with the bucks or if you're
riding with the chiefs
the most fun way to make money during
the super bowl is to bet on as many prop
bets
as humanly possible and we want to give
you an exclusive
first look at our on our favorite 40
super bowl prop bets yeah uh 40. we
we're
we're locked and loaded so kelly to kick
things off
why are betting props the most fun
and why are you so excited about br drop
zone
yeah kathy look who doesn't love having
action on
every single aspect of the game starting
off with the natural anthem the coin
flip will the first
uh play be a pass or run who scores the
first touch i mean
that is why the super bowl props are so
awesome
it gives you something to cheer for
throughout the whole game last year i
didn't even bet the game until the third
quarter
but we cast the national anthem greg
cash the coin flip we it made it so much
more fun
to have the game broken down in tiny
little quick hitter segments
lovely that was awesome and i remember
uh celebrating with you a few times
uh g-money this is very important tell
the audience what we're giving away
today my dude
all right everybody check it out
everybody check it out for everybody
21 and over draftkings is giving away
1500. i need 1500
900 in the comments right now dk dollars
uh they're giving it away we're giving
away a ps5
i'm giving away hoodies in fact i'm
about to give away some right now
hey chad i was on my phone i'm in the
comments on my phone and i was like hey
drop
some chat gifts in the comments so i'm
about to give away uh
some hoodies to some people that was
dropping some chat chad ocho cinco gifts
in the comments
john schneider got you laying on the
couch you remember when you did that
yeah john snyder you're walking away
with a hoodie
shouts out to you i got not darius
garland with you uh
he was holding up a a soccer jersey
shouts out to you
uh james james b23
shouts out to you he got he got a chat
uh gift
big mike13 he got a chat gift cabbie i
am going to keep going
just one dollar g money just one more we
gotta get to the show
a dog a dog two three four said 1500
not hundreds he said honey so we go i'm
gonna hook him up
i'm gonna give him a buddy g money i got
a question for chad
uh as a man that is a future hall of
famer in the nfl
and a hall of fame gamer do you have a
ps5 already you know what you know
what's funny
i got a ps5 for the kids i had to make
sure the kids were squared away
i have a rig i'm the pro gamer i don't
even have an xbox series excuse me i'm
sorry for missing that but i don't even
have a ps5
and since we're giving it away why don't
the one you guys have just give it to me
and seal the door no no no we can't we
can't
we promised somebody in the audience of
ps5 i'm sure you got the plug chat but
someone today is getting one of these
uh gaming systems that are like
impossible to get
um and after the show if you missed out
on all the free merch be sure to check
out draftking's free
55 million dollar prediction challenge
for a chance to win a one million dollar
top prize
draftkings is coming with that bag so
you guys know that we're adrenaline
junkies out around here we don't really
like
to take that much time to to get some
action so
let's kick it off with some quick
hitters these are our favorite
eight prop bets that usually resolve in
the first quarter or just about the end
of the first quarter
the first offensive play from squirt
ridge is interesting because last year
patrick mahomes
handed off the ball run play the year
before that tom brady
handed off the ball a run play the first
team to score
is a toss-up two because both of these
teams have high powered offenses
but let's start with some heat the first
player to score a touchdown odds right
at the bottom of the screen there
the degree of difficulty is so high and
that's why the payouts are so
big take it in digest it
g-money what should the people in the
comments be doing
cabbie let me talk to the people a
little bit
get in the comments tell us who you
think is scoring the first td
guess what i'm doing i'm giving away
hoodies as long as cappy don't cut me
off
so get in the comments and let us know
who you think
is scoring a td first
all right so so chad you saw that you
saw that list there and you know that
receivers
live for the spotlights do any of those
receivers pique your interest as the
first player to
score a touchdown in the big game uh i
think the first player that's going to
score a touchdown
is going to be travis kelsey for the
chiefs that is my home
security blanket everyone else on the
offensive side the ball is going to be
doubled
i guarantee you and i know i'm not wrong
if i'm wrong
if i'm wrong i'll delete twitter for the
rest of my life
we don't want that because you're far
too entertaining on twitter kel's you're
the expert here are you are you siding
with are you riding with chad or you did
somebody else on the board pick your
interest
chad i don't like that what is my poor
mom gonna do if she doesn't get to check
out what you're doing on twitter all day
that's all i ever hear about
did you see chad's tweet no mom some of
us have super bowl shows to do
okay chad is correct tyra kill is gonna
get double teamed all day long
i don't think that there's a ton of
value with tyrique now the cheetah
can get open so i understand but i do
think their wide receiver one is going
to be absolutely manhandled by two
different
bucks receivers travis kelsey is a big
body wide receiver point blank period
the end
he is impossible to double team chad is
correct
but i'm gonna go with the wide receiver
three maybe even a wide receiver four
after yesterday's punt return fumble for
a touchdown for the
buffalo bills and that is me cole
hardman at 17-1
i loved the andy reid gave him multiple
chances yesterday to redeem himself
i think he's going to reward his wide
receiver by letting him score the first
touchdown
17-1 this is incredible value maybe it's
because
chad is one of our friends that i'm also
looking at a wide receiver prop but on
the other team
i'm looking at mike evans he was the
first person to score a touchdown in the
divisional game he was the first person
to score a touchdown
in the afc championship game and mike
evans is going to be the first player to
score a touchdown
in the big game 55 on sunday so plus
1200
kelly you've taught me well look for
value in the picks
mike evans that's my pick g money i know
i know the handy dandy ipad or the phone
is buzzing
where are the commenters leaning on the
player to score the first time
i got i got two of them i got two of
them oh okay all right
hey hey let me introduce y'all if y'all
don't know this is the handy dandy ipad
chat this is the handy dandy right here
this is where
this is where we give away comments this
is where i connect with the people
i got handy dandy ipad greg why are you
not up there
uh i don't know what you're talking
about handy dandy ipad but just because
you got your name
handy-dandy ipad i'm going to give you a
hoodie uh okay here we go we got
chief chief hood he says grunk shouts
out to you you're walking away with
hoodie winnie the pooh is in the house
she they says tom brady shouts out to
you you're walking away jaden
rb says mahomes to watkins chief score
so you're saying sammy watkins shouts
out to you you're walking away with a
hoodie
uh i got sam steiner brady you're
walking away what are you all right i'm
done in the comments
because cabbie's gonna cut me off let me
get my tape i'm gonna give my take i'm
walking with my guy pat mahone
i'm walking with my guy pat holmes i can
see third down
third and goal you know you gotta get to
the goal line i see pat scrambling right
reaching out hitting the pylon and
scoring so i'm rocking with i'm rocking
with pat man
i like that g money he did score the
first touchdown of the super bowl last
year so
that's that's a good pick uh greg we all
know that uh the only thing you like
more
than betting on props is parlaying them
so what are you cooking up for the big
game my g
parlay parley parley parley i need that
in the comments i need that in the
comments
the first leg the first leg is going to
be one of the quickest hitters out there
the coin toss and because this is drop
zone we had to kick things off with a
drop of our own
i tried to get the private jet chad i
tried to get the private you know
man but they unfortunately they gave us
the skydiving plane they gave us the
skydiving plane
we dropped a coin from over a mile high
in the sky get in the comments tell me
uh
if you think it's going to be heads or
tails tell me if you think it's going to
be heads and tails
dk is giving me uh 500
need 500 in the comments two dk dollars
to give to one of you guys so uh get in
the comments and let me know
chad uh would you ever go skydiving bro
at home
sir you never go through i died sir i
need to be
i need to be in control of all aspects
of my life and being in the air jumping
out of plane ain't one of them
boo chad i've seen you ride a bull
listen listen that is different i
established dominance on that bull
i told him
[Laughter]
let's take a look at the tape
[Music]
that was amazing like unbelievable
tales never fails there you have it
let's
lock it in uh pull up the graphic for us
please pull up the graphic
pull up the graphic because we have to
lock this in you see leg one right there
let's say
you see the magic just happened we are
riding with tails
we are riding with tails cabbie so greg
important question who's getting the 500
and who's winning some footage my dude
i like the way you said that kevin let
me get back to the handy dandy
i'm in the comments i am in the comments
i got
uh predator x predator x shouts out to
you you said tails you're walking away
with a hoodie
i got yoinker 13. shout out to you you
said
tails you're walking with woody mikey
mikey824
you said tails you're walking away with
any cabbie the next one i'm going to
decide
who's walking away with the five honey
all right
i'm going to decide all right here we go
here we go
bam ryan wins ryan wins dfs
give me tales every time shouts out to
you rather you are walking away with the
first
500 and dk dollars uh
do not worry don't worry y'all stay
tapped in stay right here
because i'm giving out more i'm giving
out more and i'm giving out a ps5 don't
y'all want that
i need ps5 ps5 gifts in the comments
right now ps5 gives
let's go salute to you ryan well done
sir
so uh we have a lot more to cover and
let's move on to player props which has
kind of become
a specialty of of the squad ride
quarterback head to head is pure box
office
the goat and the baby goat brady and
mahomes
anytime touchdowns is our specialty that
one's always tasty
chad look at that one right there the
the the third one on the list
who are you taking in this wide receiver
head-to-head prop
are you taking tyrek hill are you taking
mike evans
oh ooh that's a tough one
that's a tough one kansas city's going
to play a lot of man-to-man that means
mike evans is going to be
one-on-one with charlotte breedman but
but even with bucks double teaming tyree
kill
he's going to get an explosive play or
two so i'm gonna have to take
tyrique wheel
tyree kill to get more receiving yards
and mike evans that's a that's a great
pick
uh chad in york chad johnson in his
prime
tyre killing his prime who wins a foot
race foot race
now yeah at the finish line is there
mcdonald's
there is mcdonald's yes i definitely win
i don't care who i'm running against
i don't it doesn't matter i'd love to
see it i
i wish we could see that uh excellent
work um all right so
let's let's move on to mvp and
two of the men that will be throwing
either tyrek hill the rock or mike evans
the rock
odds to win mvp this usually goes to the
quarterback in the last
20 years 21 years it's gone to the
quarterback
13 times patrick mahomes right at the
top of the board plus 100.
tom brady right right underneath plus
200
uh the rest of the board got a couple of
running backs got a couple of wide
receivers there
g-money i know your handy-dandy ipad is
buzzing
from excitement uh the audience has seen
the board
have you seen anything yet has it been
populated with any particular player
the odds on favor to win the super bowl
55 mvp
cabbie i'm on the ipad and um let me
talk to him this is what i need you guys
to do
get in the comments tell me who you
think is winning mvp
that's all you got to do i'm giving away
hoodies get in the comments and i'm
giving away hoodies
super simple chad you just saw the
graphic there who do you like to win
the mvp of the big game um
it's probably going to go to practical
homes it would be a second mvp
a receiver would have to have a
phenomenal game
it's been it's happened before jerry
rice obviously junior edelman's done it
before
but the chance of a receiver having a
game of that magnitude
is probably not going to happen so the
reason for the chiefs winning the game
to go that is because of the homes
and if i'm wrong if i'm wrong i'll
delete my instagram
no we don't want you to delete anything
chad come on right dude
kelsey you guys dad is looking for a
reason to delete social media and i
don't blame you
you might be on to something else uh i
know that you
celebrated when your dude von miller won
the uh super bowl mvp super bowl 50
against the carolina panthers you
probably made a bag who do you like to
win the mvp in this
uh in two sundays that was a total homer
bet von miller is my favorite player in
the league and so i had to sprinkle just
a little bit and
he absolutely made cam newton's life a
living hell
that's how a defensive player steps up
and wins in the peak
now look if you saw in the first graphic
you saw minus 305 will a quarterback win
mvp
the chances of a quarterback winning mvp
are obviously very high so chad's in the
right direction here
if the chiefs win it'll probably be
patrick mahomes if the bucks win it's
probably gonna be tom brady
but i'm gonna go on the opposite side
here i think if either team wins
it's gonna be on the backs of their
defense
we saw the bucks yesterday even though
tom brady threw three interceptions
they won that game for the buccaneers
the chiefs defense
shut down josh allen who is i in my
opinion an
up-and-coming mvp maybe next year he has
a nod
this kid has a lot of potential and he
was absolutely stifled sacked several
times and he
even bounced the football off someone's
head not beside this is beside the point
i think it's going to be a defensive
player i'm going with the honey badger
the landlord as they like to call him in
kansas city tyron matthew
he's not even on there i think he's
probably fifty to one
oh forty to one there we go thank you to
our producers look
i think that that is what's gonna happen
somebody is going to make tom brady
throw up a duck
it's gonna be that pass rush and who's
gonna come down with the duck
the landlord maybe he gets two in one
game and somehow
wins this mvp nod for me at 40 to 1. i
love
everything that you just said kells and
again i'm learning from you i i
i'm gonna go with the long value play
someone with long odds
the defensive line yesterday in both
games were tremendous like both
quarterbacks
talk about josh allen and uh and aaron
charles rogers were under so much
pressure
so in the big game i'm looking at either
frank clark
because he had two sacks yesterday or
shaquille barrett had so had like 47
pressures
on rogers yesterday had three sacks so
it's a coin toss maybe we got to send
the skydiving plane back up in the air
for me to
to pick but i'm leading frank clark or
shaquille barrett
uh g-money has the audience chimed in
with who they like
to win mvp is it just one of the
quarterbacks or are they going off the
board too
cabbie let me tap into the handy dandy i
see all types of stuff
i'm in the comments b dance256 says
kelsey y'all better stop playing
i better stop playing with v dan he said
travis kelsey he's locked in you're
walking away with a hoodie
i got a k-pop saying tyreek easy money
he's going for 250 yards oh my goodness
chad he going for 250. he did listen
he went for ewing for 200 in the first
half the first time they played him
ain't no telling what might happen this
time
that's right that that yeah man
shouts out to you k pop you're walking
away with a hoodie i got one more cabbie
a roger
says a rogers 12 says pat mahomey and
i'ma end it with that one
i'm gonna end it with that one shouts
out to you a rogers 12 year walk away
with i'm gonna end it with that because
i'm also rocking with pat
mahomes i mean i see the chiefs winning
the games and in order for them to win
the game
pack got a ball so hey g-money does that
hurt
okay let's move on let's actually move
on to the second leg of your big game
parlay how about that
yeah i mean let's do it let's do it this
time i need the audience to decide with
me
uh the second leg prop is will the first
play
in the second half be a run or a pass
drop run or passes in the comments
give me gifts give me runners running
gives give me passing gifts i need all
type of
runs or pass uh in the comments i'm
giving out another 500
dk dollars chad look it keep this bro
i'm going to read out some comments and
then you're gonna help me decide
who's getting this 500 okay okay before
we do that chad
before we do that you played in a super
bowl
you're an nfl legend i want you to take
the audience behind the curtains and
give us paint the picture
of what the the locker room looks like
at halftime
and also your process during halftime in
a regular game or for what you remember
from that super bowl that you played in
well i played in one super bowl and i
remember half time madonna was
performing
quiet inside is belichick so you already
know you know they run a very militant
tight
ship and um defense was on one side
offense was on another
and they were going over the game plan
we were leading by one point at the half
i believe it was ten nine if i'm not
mistaken
and that's correct that's pretty that's
that's pretty much it that's pretty much
it
it was very very very quiet nobody's
screaming what much going on at halftime
uh chad did you refuel with some
mcdonald's do you remember that at
halftime
and did you ever refill the donut you
know what i didn't i didn't have access
to mcdonald's but i did have it
pre-game so i had a pre-game meal so i
didn't need to do it again
that would just be excessive
[Music]
you are uh you are a marvel of science
my friend that's
incredible uh g-money uh what are you
seeing in the comments section
is there are they leaning run as the
first play of the second half or
pass as the first play of the second hey
cabbie i see a whole bunch of creativity
going on i got young gutters in
mikey824 i think mikey won if he didn't
we're going to give him another hoodie
uh they're both looking look at they got
gifts running i got wonder woman up top
and that looks like rocky
rocky at the bottom uh they're all over
the place i got predator
x says run uh coop deville says
pass shawty shouts out to you
cooperville actually everybody
i named you guys would walk away with
hoodies 88d says pass
best hawks19 says run cabbie uh chad
this is this is
i got i got two two comments now this is
where i'm gonna need you to help me out
here bro
all right i got in mac
22. he said he got the forrest gump gift
going
he got the forrest gump gift so that
means run you got fours running
so then i got slim slatey
saying pass they got a they got a pass
to godwin they said
they said stuff i don't know what mac
has been watching what football season
he's paid attention to the past
15 16 weeks but when teams come out of
the half
they throw the ball they throw the ball
it's obvious
it's common sense it's common knowledge
to do with the casual football fan and
he should know that and i'm upset
at mac nasty mac 20 whatever
chad you played in you played in super
bowl 46.
wait wait cabbie wait wait wait cubby
wait wait i'm so sorry i just i just
gotta throw it to my graphic bro cause i
got it i got it
okay i gotta so we're we're locking it
in we're locking it in
we're locking it y'all saw that magic
it's pass right there y'all saw that
magic it is past
uh thank you we we see the graphic now
you both are getting hoodies you both
are getting hoodies but uh
my guys slim slim you walking away with
that 500 slim you all the way with that
500 and dk dallas
and um i'm giving away the ps5 student
i'm giving away the ps5 soon
y'all stay tapped in don't go nowhere
put ps5's in the comments man put ps5 in
the comments
congratulations slim that's that's
tremendous okay chad
real quick you played super bowl 46 and
the first play
after halftime was a pass to you
what do you remember about that
particular play or your game plan
new england's game plan against the
giants um
i don't remember the game plan was
against the giants i know i wasn't part
of much of it
but i do remember catching the proudest
moment in my career
i caught a pass from tom brady in a
super bowl
you know what for that i deserve a
jacket it could be yellow of some sort
hang it up and can
[Laughter]
uh yes you do deserve a jacket that for
many of your other
um achievements so um
let's move on to exotic props
this is a very fun one because these are
this this board is kind of wild
gatorade shower color length of the
anthem caused a stir amongst the br
betting crew last year
it was under the two minutes thank you
demi lovato
that one at the bottom of the screen is
very interesting will tom brady retire
after the game
might rob gronkowski re-retire after the
game that is
those are some pretty long odds kind of
juicy g-money
how does the audience earn a hoodie and
a hoodie in this round
cabbie this is what the audience got to
do drop your exotic
prop locks in the comments i'm giving
away hoodies all right look look look
go to the gif press uh type in exotic
and then whatever pops up put it in the
comments
there's gonna be
there's gonna be a lot of joe exotics in
the comments uh kelly which one of these
is the most fun to bet
oh you already mentioned that the
national anthem was super fun i remember
it was you me
greg there was a bunch of produce we
were all just sitting around having fun
we had our
stopwatches out on our phones and ready
to go
uh gatorade color's fun but i did
lose a lot of money on that one time i
thought i had some good insight chad can
you make a call
and see if we can figure out what color
the gatorade is going to be or maybe can
you facetime talk i can
ask him if he's going to retire i can do
that right now
if we have time
[Laughter]
do you think tom would actually answer
your call that would be fun right
i'm gonna go okay
i'm gonna we're gonna do this it's gonna
be a fun game i love when chad calls his
famous friends
um i'm gonna go national anthem i think
this is like
the start of something really awesome
right you want to win a
a bet right out of the gate you're
excited they always put on such a great
performance so that's where i'm going in
this one
so wait kel's eric church and jasmine
sullivan are performing the national
anthem
are you going over or under the two
minutes chad and i actually talked about
this in pregame
so i'm the country music fan he's the r
b
fan we both know that these two can drag
it out they have the long notes
i'm excited i think this one actually
might go over
two minutes is a long time i think last
year was like a minute 30. it was like
quick but i do think with these two and
and kind of interweaving their two music
types i think we might see it over here
chad are you with cows on this one i am
definitely with chaos on this one
jasmine something
is very very soulful and we know it
comes to country music country musics
are always drawing out stories because
there's all the story lines to it
even though it's the even though it's
the anthem it's going to get drawn out
past the two minute mark i guarantee you
and if i'm wrong
i'll delete facebook
[Laughter]
as the lone canadian on this crew i
gotta
i gotta salute abel in the weekend and i
like that
first song of the halftime performance
prophet i've never seen that before
but i you know i think the hills is in
contention
blinding lights will probably close out
the show so i'm saying star boy
is how he starts his halftime
performance comes out with a banger
electrifies the crowd and then away we
go uh
g-money the ti the audience has had some
time to sit with these exotic prop bets
what are you seeing in the comments
cabbie i'm in the comments uh i see uh
i see first time i see first half time
song i see that
i see the length of anthem i see that i
see the color of the gatorade
i see that but i'm just going to give
away uh
i'm going to give away hoodies to people
who are giving me exotic gifts cabbie
so brown boy brown boy shouts out to you
you're walking away with a hoodie for
your exotic
gift you got to show us grace you can't
just be show intelligent money
all right here we go here we go brown
boy look at he got the nice little dog
look it looks like airbnb
that is not exotic that's not exotic
don't give up i need to see
tigers i need to see carol baskin i need
to see some funny stuff
whoa you guys bad vibes bad vibes over
there bad boys in the comments
bad bots in the comments i'm giving away
these hoodies here we go
we got je 15 he's he got the turtle
i mean kelly you don't like turtles no
that's not exotic
yeah turtles are exotic you're still
right you're still
riding the bad vibes we do not want
those
all right i need better gifts we need
better gifts i'm done it's too many bad
vibes going on
uh i'm rocking with gatorade i'm rocking
with the gatorade i like i i i i
i cannot wait to see the coach just get
doused and gatorade like who doesn't
like that
and you know that andy reed doesn't move
too fast though so they'll probably get
him
i don't think bruce arians does either
awesome that's a good thing it's gonna
be a nice gatorade bath regardless
get on draftkings lock in these exotic
props
uh you don't even need to know that much
about football in order to have fun and
bet on these
and even when you've bet all the props
that you can you can still play
draftkings 55 million dollar prediction
challenge
and earn even more including an instant
prize of up to 25 grand just for signing
up
and the top prize is a one million
dollar
giveaway on game day draftkings coming
with the bag salute
so g-money uh it is time for your third
leg of the parlay
and i think i know where you're going
with this one
cabbie i just talked about it the third
leg is all about the gatorade
shower what color will it be let's take
a look at all the different colors
there's the graphic it's right
there in front of you uh but for this
prop parlay draftkings is offering two
options
orange and yellow together versus the
field i tapped in with chad
earlier this week to decide what color
we were going to be riding
but before we show you before we show
you get in the comments and tell me
what color gatorade you think me and
chad picks like
what color do y'all think we picked
everybody knows nobody likes the orange
why is it the favorite kelly you just
cut me off you just
cut me off on the most on one of the
most important parts
like come on everybody wants to know
that they're winning i mean that they
have a chance to win 500
dk dollars right now every that's what
they that's what they're here for
they want to know that they have a
chance to win 500 dk dollars if they
guess right
chad when you play did you have a
specific color that you needed in order
to give you
fuel do you have a favorite gatorade
color no
no i mean but i mean kevin you should
know me should know me right now we've
known each other for a while now you
know the fuel that i take before
games is coke coke with no ice from
mcdonald's and so there's no need to
really
why would i saturate my body with
gatorade during the game
i put the gas in before it even started
chad you you legitimately are a marvel
of science your body needs to be studied
my dude
um so uh yeah g-money uh i think you i
think you
cooked up something special for this one
all right i think it's time to play the
video
so look man tapped in with gatorade and
i got it uh you looking real 85-ish you
know they're number one
to 30. so pick a number and we go ride
with that gatorade color
as the gatorade that's going to be
poured on the coach when the super bowl
is finished
i like my homes i like my homes and my
homes where it's not number 15 right
yes sir yes sir so i'm going to go with
15
and 5's locking in 15. i'm locking in 15
and 15 will be the color of the gatorade
shower
i think i'm right for some reason i
promise you this is my handwriting this
is 15 right here
85 is going with red i'm going red
let me sip some of this man we got to
celebrate real quick
we got to celebrate let me sip some of
this
[Music]
let's go we're going with red oh
wow that that took a nice left turn just
just wash away all those bad vibes from
last year's super bowl hanji money
salute to your niners
the color was red which makes sense the
the chiefs
and the bucks uh this year there so lock
it in
uh the for this parlay draftkings is
offering
orange and yellow or the field so that
means
it's red we are riding with the field
so greg who's getting that 500 cabbie
i'm in the comments i am in the comments
uh kobe
uh kobe eisenberg says
clear hmm that's interesting just like
it's interesting
shouts out to you kobe you're walking
away with a hoodie ploppy poppy shouts
out to you poppy poppy is rocking with
the blue
poppy is rocking with the blue okay king
of sports says red
okay a rogers says uh
red i see uh i i
yeah they're all over the place kevin
they are all over the place i'm gonna
just get to it
i'm gonna just get to it everybody i
said y'all walking away with a hoodie
now i'm gonna get to the five honey
right now y'all ready
here we go here we go all right yup got
it go
blue 8k says reed
getting showered with the red
shouts out to you bro you walking away
with the 500
and dk dollars congratulations sir all
right so we're gonna
we're gonna pull it back in and get to
something a little bit more traditional
let's take a look at the over under wait
wait cabbie wait cabbie wait wait before
i
you can i just i gotta throw my graphic
up i gotta throw my grass
here we go there it is y'all just saw
the magic at the bottom
y'all just saw the magic at the bottom
we are locked in y'all see it right here
go put this in right now uh
and we're getting closer and closer
to ps5 time
now kathy now we can talk over under
after after the people see they gotta
lock this in they
you know what i mean they're locking
that in this is my bad over under okay
so total points this is always a big one
that's one of the most
more traditional props 56 total
touchdowns is juicy
total touchdown passes is tempting but
kelly over under is 56 points
has there been any live movement in the
past 24 hours since
the end the conclusion of both af afc
and nfc championship games
it's wild to me cabbie every single year
the wise guys come in on the under in
the super bowl
it doesn't matter i don't get it it
makes no sense to me
uh but they did again this one open 57
now down to 56
i don't know why they don't just wait
until game time this one's gonna go back
up so i guess now if you like the over
bet it
if you like the under i think you should
wait greg the audience is seeing the
board that's that's that's good at intel
cal's they've seen the board
most of these props are are all offense
but you're tapped in with the comments
section
what are you seeing so far uh cabbie i'm
seeing a lot of ps5 so let me talk
drop your over under locks in the
comments
preferably the overs because you know
apparently cabbie
and kelly say i only rock with the overs
chad thank you
me man we gotta get we got to get you
around more me and chad we be vibing
while you all be hating but uh i'm
giving away hoodies i'm giving away
hoodies in the comments i'm giving away
hoodies
listen cows and i aren't hating we just
bet money
that you can't hit 90 mile an hour
fastballs or catch
one-handed footballs and then because
chad is
was also also an athlete or hall of fame
athlete he was riding with you but we
don't we're not hating we're just
saying in athletic competitions
sometimes
yeah you fall below expectation okay
listen on the on the board one of the
more interesting
uh props there was over under two and a
half players
to complete a pass what's the deal with
this one
yeah you saw that that it's juiced
towards the under and it should be
because unless blaine gabbert or chad
hinnie makes an appearance
i don't think we're gonna see any
trickery in the super bowl now we've
seen julian adam and throw a pass we've
seen taysom hill
but neither one of those teams is in
this mix i just don't see
andy reid or bruce arians trying to get
too creative here so i think the under
is probably the play barring anything
catastrophic
chad as a as a former receiver i mean we
know that you had a specialty
in obviously catching but kicking point
after touchdowns or field goals
were you ever involved in any trickery
like a
wide receiver toss and do you think
we'll see one in the big game
you know what i was involved in a rob
receiver toss when i played with t.o in
20
in 2010 if i'm not mistaken maybe it's
2009
i threw him up threw him at the ball it
wasn't complete though
but i think you have arguably the best
quarterback to ever play
in the nfl going with the baby girl
who's probably going to surpass
him as the best quarterback to ever play
there's no need for trickery when you
have two of the best
at the helm already doing it so i don't
think it's going to happen nothing's
going to happen at all
great inside i'm going to go with the on
the other side because i want to see
just i love the high jinks and travis
kelsey on on the chiefs
has thrown three passes in his nfl
career he's one for three
and he had one interception but this
might be the travis kelsey
redemption game a lot of people in the
comments have already been saying
lock in travis kelsey for an mvp imagine
he completes
a touchdown pass yo my money's on travis
kelsey so i'm saying yes
over two and a half players to complete
a pass in
in the big game g-money you're tapped in
is anybody riding with me
or are they riding with the more
sensible bet under with kelly and chad
cabby surprisingly surprisingly i think
the audience likes the
the plus money i see a lot of over
enderman over danny dime season
over grant barthold over
uh k-pop over shouts out to you you want
a hoodie
uh d geek over best hawk 19
over i'm going to keep going kathy
because they're all riding the over
over over so guess what i'm gonna ride
the over with you cabbie i'm gonna rock
with the people
i'm a rock with you we riding with the
over uh
chad i know you made a very good point
you made a very good point
we don't need to see that we don't need
to see nobody else throwing the ball
but you know in these situations coaches
get in the games and they uh
they they they they start to do stuff
that they probably shouldn't
so i don't know i see a coach uh making
this play call trying to get creative in
the situation
and uh hitchhiking you're shaking your
head why are you shaking your head
you get creative and you have fun you do
things you haven't done during the
regular season
you don't do it in the game the most
important game of the season
to win a chip that's not the game you do
it and you do exotic formation
and using players you've never used
before to throw the ball when you have a
tom brady and a practicum home so
everybody that took over
something is wrong with all of you and
we're going to get you tested at some
point
[Laughter]
you know what made me think of remember
last year patrick they did like
that spin formation like they spun like
the
patch of your hair it was that was that
was wild and i think they actually
caused some ferrari something from
ferrari something yeah
yeah yo load it up load up the
six-speeder okay so um
kels we've let uh greg have some fun
with his uncut gems parlay
but let's move let's bring in another
expert into the conversation
uh you brought a special guest so we
welcome him to
be our drop zone i sure did johnny
avello from the draft keying sports
is going to be joining us one of my
favorite guys i've known this guy for
almost a decade he's
been in the industry since before i was
born
welcome in mr johnny avello
uh director of the draftking sportsbook
here in las vegas
thanks for hanging out with us johnny
hey kell how are you
just living the dream i am on the dk
app going oh my gosh these guys have put
together
so many props but before we get to that
i have to know
we got new states entering the
marketplace every single day draftkings
is on the ground floor
we've got almost half the states now
able to legally bet
sports what a ride this has been the
last few years it's so exciting
i have to know is this going to be the
biggest super bowl handle we've ever
seen
well based on the action we received
from the nfc
and afc championship games last weekend
this is going to exceed
all previous numbers so yes
i'm expecting a colossal handle
i love to hear it the more bets the
better makes the game
so much more fun okay so we're doing a
prop show so i have to know
which prop bet do you think is going to
be the most popular for this
super bowl well of all the thousands
that are going to be available
i believe the first touchdown scorer
will write the most
business uh guys like travis kelsey at
six to one
mike evans at 12 to one and a gronk at
22-1 are going to be
very popular choices i like it i'm going
to take me
cole hardman johnny do you think i have
a chance to cash that ticket hey it's
your money kel do what you want with it
oh no all right so we're talking about
all of these i mean i remember when i
first moved to vegas you would get a
packet
this thick of super bowl bets you guys
price
so many you have thousands of bets which
was the most difficult for you
to come up with the best number on
well it's going to be one of the newer
ones that we're working on
think about the prop that i conceived a
few years back
what will be the average number of all
the jersey numbers that score a
touchdown in a game
those type of propositions require
extensive research
and applied mathematics so it takes time
i totally get you there i'm excited to
hear what else you guys are coming up
with
all right so as far as prop bets go what
is the worst beat you've ever seen
you've spent
how many super bowls in a sports book i
know you've got to have some crazy
stories
boy i have a bunch for house for the
house
and bettors alike it was uh the 2015
whole game where russell wilson threw
that pick from the one-yard line with 20
seconds remaining
millions could have changed hands
including one gentleman who wagered a
million with me
on the patch and i remember asking him
why he made the bet and he said
i had a feeling yeah he sure did
but for props in general was probably
the super bowl 20 1986
pats versus the bears william
refrigerator pr
perry i don't know if you remember him
cal but he was a defensive lineman it
was used to ensure yard just yardage
situations
uh during the season and he scored a few
tds
we put up a line if he would score in a
super bowl we opened it up at 12 to 1
and it got bent all the way down to nine
to five
so it's a blowout late in the third
quarter and the bears are up
at the one yard line and guess who comes
off the bench perry instead of walter
payton
no less yep he scored a ton my gosh
especially in those days and the sports
book
took a bath i bet okay johnny uh what is
the most exciting part
with your job at draftkings during the
super bowl
well there's always a tremendous amount
of work to be done leading up to the
game
and uh and then there's the in play
wagering after kickoff
but there's going to be a significant
amount of house decisions
in many different markets and that is
pretty exciting for a bookmaker
i love to hear you guys johnny avello
absolute legend out here in las vegas
director of
the draftkings sportsbook johnny thanks
for hanging out with us today
my pleasure kelly that was awesome
appreciate your insights and information
johnny and
as you can see johnny just doesn't count
his winnings he weighs them on the scale
behind
them so as an og we we salute you homie
now let's talk uh yes or no props and
then i believe
g-money has a ps5 to give away let's see
the graphic please
g-money check in with your people this
is this one there are some spicy ones
here
drop your locks in the comments i'm
giving away hoodies let me make this
clear
if you're repeating comments in the in
the in the comments
that's not how i'm going to select you
so i need takes i need
you to drop your locks uh in the
comments on these yes no props
safety to be scored is nice special
teams touchdown is always exciting
uh chad what is your favorite yes or no
prop on the board
obviously my favorite which i would
probably win would be the last play to
kneel because i can name the team that's
going to kneel last i can name the
player that's going to take the kneel
and that's pretty much it so that's my
favorite problem because i'd probably
win
if i do take that back
which is who well obviously it's gonna
be the chiefs
i mean anyone with common knowledge of
the game of football that was
established in 1946
became at actual nfl but know that
chiefs are going to win a game based off
matchups and if you don't know that then
you don't play chess
so you're going patrick mahomes victory
formation
we should lock that in you should lock
it in and
if i'm wrong i'll delete my only fans
no no no no not even no we need the only
fans we need the only fans
kelly what's your favorite yes or no
prophet
i just can't even stop laughing my face
hurts so much i miss chad johnson so
much all right uh
look so i'm gonna tell you guys what
you're not gonna bet you're not gonna
bet the safety this used to be ten to
one twelve to one when i first moved to
vegas
and the bookmakers took an absolute bath
on it like three super bowls in a row i
don't know if
you remember the broncos seattle game
the ball goes right over peyton's head
safety right out of the gate and after
that they said no more value on the
safety we're going to charge you guys a
premium so don't even waste your time
betting that one one that i think is
really interesting
and it is nice plus money i think it's
plus 230 is a missed extra point
no disrespect to mr sukup or mr butker
but i do think that we're going to see a
mixed us mixed
extra point because since they moved it
back since 2015 these are no longer
automatic
i know chad can kick a pat i've seen it
but can chad
kick a new p-a-t is the question
it is tough to do we've seen these guys
miss
quite a few this year look this is a big
stage plus 230 plus
i got to take it here and think that we
may see one
chad have you been on a field to i mean
we saw you kick a 60 yard have you been
on a field recently
to stretch out that leg no i haven't
been but if
you need if
and listen i'm going to apologize on the
front end because i i
i'm bringing some bad vibes but the yes
no prop
i'm leaning towards is a missed field
goal i remember a couple of years ago
stephen gotkowski and greg zerline they
both smith
they both missed field goals in that
13-3
patriots uh super bowl so
apologies to ryan suck up apologies here
but harrison bucker
but i think there's going to be a missed
field goal you had to bring up greg the
leg didn't you
i did which is a great nickname um
g-money i'm sorry for the bad vibes are
there other bad other bad vibes in the
comment section
oh i don't know about bad vibes okay
good it's only
it's only good vibes only in the
comments uh here we go
sam skidmost says miss phil go yes
so shouts out to them they're walking
away with it a dog two three four yes
walk away with a hoodie uh landon falls
says you're right kelly
shouts out to you landon you're walking
away with a hoodie mgo
blue 16s talking about the miss field
goal shouts out to you you're walking
away with a hoodie
all right that's it for the comments uh
i'ma give you guys my take i'm gonna
tell you guys how it's gonna happen
all right the last play
neil is gonna happen so that's what i'm
rocking with i'm rocking with yes
it's gonna happen it's gonna be patrick
mahomes taking a knee
and then guess what they gonna do cabbie
slap hands
me slap hands in the comments right now
slap hands
yes sir and then andy reed is going to
get a gatorade shower
and then probably enjoy a cheeseburger
right after the game
i was clapping because i'm excited this
is the moment
where we're going to give away a ps5 ps5
to give away to one
of you and we're gonna do it right now
um
but but to win it you're gonna have to
decide
whether to bet on chad johnson or to
fade
chad johnson and this is how we're gonna
do it we're gonna show chad
15 receivers that have caught passes
in the last five super bowls 15
receivers
that have caught passes in the last five
super bowls and um
all you have to do chad is just name the
players we're going to get kelly to
establish the line and then in the
comments
you guys choose whether chad or you guys
predict
where the chat will hit the over or the
under kells
what is the line oh this is tough you
guys are putting me on the spot here
look we're back in studio chad did
really well
at some of these like mainly like pop
artists
but when it came to knowing his own
quarterbacks my dude
struggled so i'm gonna go somewhere in
the middle my gut's telling me around
the number ten
so let's just for for nine and a half
let's just do nine and a half
i think he's i think the under is gonna
hit but i'm gonna do it just because we
can't have a push
okay so the line is nine and a half tell
us in the comments if you think chad
will correctly guess over or under nine
and a half receivers
that have caught passes in the super
bowl and then afterwards g-money's gonna
pick one of you guys and give you a ps5
chad what do you have to say to the
people that are fading you immediately
i don't think you can get over nine and
a half receivers the people that are
fading me i just want to tell you
and i want you to look directly in my
face look into my eyes
looking to my right eye because that's
my good one but i love you
i love you all right
let's get to the game shall we here's
the first image
tyreque correct easy well done
next one
here incorrect and this is also not fair
that you're you're you're i have to know
these individuals
based off facial recognition like on my
iphone
i would have liked to see in a jersey
maybe a number and you could have
like picking out the just clear the name
off the back
and that would have been better i mean
some of these guys wear helmets and i
might not know all of them because
you know if you go outside of my hair
precursors listen
enough with the we we see what you're
trying to do we see what you're trying
to do and you're saying it's not let's
get to the next photo
it's not fair next photo please okay
that's julian edelman
yeah he looks like the best former
teammate correct
next photo
hey that's all 49ers
yeah yeah samuel he's bald
he falls next you better get harder
otherwise i'm mad at the producer
oh that mcdonald new orleans new orleans
what's his name
chad what's his name huh not dion
what is his name
greg no healthy not not dion
yeah no we're just we just want to make
it official what is this receiver's name
even though he's your dog i can't i
can't hear cabbie
oh oh okay well greg can you hear me
or i'm sorry okay hear me yeah
yeah you can hear me all right who you
said this guy plays for the saints
what is his real name
what is wrong with me what is wrong with
me what's his name
i just said i'm gonna give you look at
mine
i don't know five more seconds
five four the dot dion
hey manuel sanderson yeah
you just got it you got it you got it
this is what i had to do just give me
real quick while we're going
i had to think of i did the show at nfl
films last year
and we did emanuel centers in the titan
we did kills
but looking at the faces it's still it's
throwing me off because i'm trying to
remember
and everything's jogging through my head
and it's messing me up but i'm ready
let's go
okay all right so you're at five the
line is nine and a half let's go to the
next receiver
oh he's got a receiver that's a that
looks like a tight end he's huge
you know the neck head that's not a
receiver
we get we guarantee you that's a
receiver and this person has cut a
pass in a super bowl what is his name
who is that i don't think we met
personally which is why i'm not able to
to get the facial recognition like an
iphone
right now and i just i'm unsure
all right just take a wild guess and
then we're going to move on can't take a
wild guess because that would be very
rude
uh that would be very rude of me to take
august just throwing him out there
so you don't know this person oh that
personally no
okay that is robert woods oh my goodness
rob rob gain weight
problem gained weight he looks different
i was trying
yeah in his neck that dude is just doing
a bunch of you know [ __ ] humor
whatever okay next next receiver please
these ds
[Laughter]
what year is this this is
this the last the last five this this is
within the last five years
you know him chad you know who this is
okay i'm i'm
putting up the clock five four three
two and one
i'm not that is all shawn jeffrey can i
give him tina oh shawnee i'm sorry
not greg you already did enough
this is this is not fair this is what
we're doing is not fair be
supposed to know everybody based off of
how they're how they look
how am i supposed to know that because
you
interview your your brethren all the
time my dude
you meet these i cats
seen i haven't seen some of these people
in almost in
years and everybody wears a helmet so
dig
dig deep into the into the mental vault
here's your next receiver
okay that's sammy i know sami save me
from the crib all right
correct sammy watkins next
oh my dog that's again again
that's teddy again junior again yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i beat him
running so that's how i know who that is
next receiver please whatever dog we
work out together
we got together sunu we work hard
together come on
muhammad sununu okay i thought you're
going to pull the same movie you did
before or you're like oh that's my dog
and not name it but
you're correct eight receivers correct
we have a few more to go next receiver
please
man
see that's not fair see how y'all this
would happen
you know when you get up in age like me
like stuff like this happens he it was a
time when my grandma didn't even know
who i was
so that's what i'm going through right
now
and what we're going to give you is a
five count can i get it can i get a team
just give me the team two one
no hints okay next is nelson aguilar
oh wait nelson look different you get a
little weight too
you know what that's a bad angle that's
a bad name cause because that workout
would know
that's a great angle that is a great
next receiver please
next receiver oh
you know him chad yeah cuz we chad you
totally know this one
yes and why is this why do people why
are people's names slipping my mind
right now
you know i know i do you
this dude might actually message you
after after the show
you probably know this is not this is
not fair
five four three
two one hey where where why are you why
are you counting
are you counting guys man we gotta we
gotta play station five to give away
uh chad okay next let's go now that is
torrey smith
i know that's true tori i'm sorry
is that amendola that is adamant though
correct okay like a bachelor too
he does all right we have two receivers
left all right come on let's go
you're at nine you just need one more to
get to the over next receiver please
wow who is that
hey we'll just get can i get the team
just give me a team
no i'm looking at the necklace
he played yesterday oh
that's me cole huh oh g money
yeah you are correct everybody
every for everybody that faded me for
everybody that faded me
i told you i told you i told you
you never bet against oso and nothing do
the last one
do the last one because i think he would
only had nine
had greg not giving him two come on
just for fun because we have a we have
the playstation giveaway just for fun
here's the last receiver
just for fun
hey 7-eleven that's hogan always open
nice work yes chris he would have won he
would have won anyway
let's go it's congratulations that's not
fair
but the way what you that's not fair i
mean because you're just giving me faces
you're just giving me faces you know
and these are i haven't seen and you
killed it i haven't seen some of these
individuals
in years and years and like i'm having
to base everything off just seeing your
face
like you can't do that to me you know
you put me on the spot now you can have
people texting me and mad at me oh you
don't know me now
oh it's not like that i'm just old i
even have an aarp you have a lot of
apologies to me
[Laughter]
uh i yo uh rip to your mentions chad
listen it is that time t money please
let us know who is walking away with a
ps5
they need to give it to me for what
y'all just put me through
i'm in the comments i am in the comments
i got je
15 saying over he was rocking with you
in the over chad best hulk
19 was rocking with you and over shouts
out to y'all y'all walking away with
some hood
some hoodies i'm sorry sweet crypto
saying chad is a beast he's yeah chad is
a beast you're walking away with a
hoodie
uh i got jay cavistrano he was rocking
with the over chat
the audience was rocking with you they
were rocking with you
uh shout out to you guys but i think
it's time
it is time we need the drum roll
all right walking away with the ps5
i don't even got a ps5 so shout out to
you man i don't have one either
my guy predator x
predator x shouts out to you you are
walking away with the ps5
let me read the comment he said chad
johnson is the man
he got me no worries chad he had all his
faith in you
he had all his faith in you just like
how i did that i knew you was going up
that's what i'm talking i knew you was
going up bro i'm talking about to get
him back more we need to get chad back
more
the vibes we're vibing we're back we're
back like best friends
congratulations the gang is the gang is
here
we are yeah the gang is here
uh guys if you learned anything today
and let it be that you can't beat the
super bowl
without throwing a dart at the dartboard
all week we're going to be looking to
you to send us your legendary
big game prop videos um tell us who
you're betting on
and if you want to be social featured on
our social channels
or on our shows send us your legendary
locks your legendary pick videos
because we love seeing them uh are gonna
keep going
because uh we wanna say thank you to
draftkings for the 1500 dk dollars
um they're giving away a lot more if you
want to play their
55 million dollar prediction challenge
video
or challenge game excuse me get an
instant prize for signing up
and a chance at a one million dollar top
prize
wait wait wait wait wait wait hold on
hold on hold on
yes you know you know i'm not getting
out of here without hooking my people up
man i gotta hook him up a dog two three
four enjoy that he's showing love to the
person that uh
won the one the ps5 i like that those
are good vibes shout out to you a dog
you're walking away with a hoodie rick
uh oh my gosh chiefs fan 2021 said it
was rigged those are bad vibes you're
not walking away
big papa joe uh big papa joe
it's a lot of bad vibes no bad vibes in
the comments no bad bops in the box
okay the the the o26 ui congrats
predator
wade0821 congrats m go
blue congratulations
i'm done i'm done i'm done okay sunset
box for g money in the comments listen
alongside kelly stewart
greg ivory and one of our favorite
humans nfl legend
chad ochocinco johnson uh the squad ride
is back
on big game sunday for a big game
special so that's sunday february the
7th
so tap in with the with the bleacher
report app
and lastly if you're cooking up a
legendary pick video of your own
here are a few legendary picks from our
good friends at draftkings
to keep you inspired see you guys later
what's happening now players and players
what's up guys the big game is coming up
but right now
we're talking about the coin toss what
color is that chill beverage gonna be
yellow gatorade blue gatorade red
gatorade purple gatorade
is it gonna be heads or is it gonna be
tail i don't know what kind of tail that
was catch
equals heads a drop equals tails
and it's red gatorade
heads i predict the coin toss is gonna
be heads
look like the color is blue players
don't add me
[Music]
so
[Music]
you